focus of the conversation politically
and culturally is still on twitter
twitter is still the place for that so
that people on say youtube or rumble and
other things or people that are
reporters or whatever you want to call
them journalists at cnn or at the new
york times they're still reporting on
what's going on on twitter so that's why
i think this is important so if you're
watching this and going well i'm not on
twitter i don't really care about
twitter it's like that still is ground
zero for
the conversation um so the washington
post had an interesting take on this
here's a beautiful headline from the
washington post elon musk's twitter
investment could be bad news for free
speech
it's literally the reverse of the truth
which is simply perfect for the
washington post elon made a point
over the course of the last few weeks of
saying i want to defend free speech i
don't like the way twitter is doing it i
am here
now putting my money where my mouth is
to ensure that they will be more
respectful of free speech principles but
of course washington post's
editorial about that was that it's going
to somehow harm uh free speech
but elon despite the washington post the
washington post owned by jeff bezos by
the way amazon's jeff bezos uh the
washington post sorry um here's some of
the things that are happening right now
going on on twitter related to free
speech well elon musk do you want an
edit button this is something people
have talked about for a long time
because you know occasionally you
actually mistype something or i find
iphone autocorrect is actually horrible
and doesn't warn me about words that are
mis-typed and sometimes confuses other
words and puts spaces between things and
all sorts of crazy stuff and you realize
it literally one second later
now the issue is if you were to add an
edit button do they have to acknowledge
that there was an edit what if it's
already got a thousand retweets there's
all sorts of stuff but this is something
that people have been clamoring about
literally for 10 years and then finally
one day later after elon musk says that
twitter communications now that
everyone's asking yes we've been working
on an edit feature since last year no we
didn't get the idea from a poll
we're kicking off testing within the
twitter blue labs in the coming months
to learn what works what doesn't and
what's possible now look
again without saying that twitter is the
most important thing in the world here
whether twitter has an edit button or
not is sort of secondary now we'll get
to the meat of this because the meat of
this is about free speech and our
ability to communicate with each other
not the government saying you can
communicate with each other but but
private citizens ability to communicate
with each other in the modern world and
elon musk is clearly trying to defend
that unless i am being completely duped
right now and everybody else is too that
seems to be what's going on here so
we've got some info from the daily wire
elon musk contacted the babylon b before
a substantial share of before buying a
substantial share of twitter according
to the christian satire's chief
executive musk is a fan of the babylon b
which is currently suspended from
twitter for an article that jokingly
named health and human services
assistant secretary rachael at bean as
man of the year and was hosted on the
site's podcast at the end of last year
according to babylon b ceo seth dylan
the world's richest man consulted with
the babylon bee before purchasing a 9.2
stake in twitter musk reached out to us
before he polled his followers about
twitter's commitment to free speech
dylan reported he wanted to confirm that
we had in fact been suspended he even
used on a call that he might need to buy
twitter now he's the largest shareholder
and has a seat on the board twitter has
thus far refused to revoke its decision
to lock the babylon bees account
according to dylan the company wrote our
support team has determined that a
violation did take place and therefore
we will not overturn the decision now
there's a couple interesting things here
so the babylon b
is suspended for quite literally making
a joke
quite literally making a joke now we
know that the ayatollah
is on twitter we know that hamas is on
twitter we know that terror
organizations like antifa are on twitter
or blacklivesmatter is on twitter and
there's all sorts of bad people that say
horrible things on twitter
in my estimation as long as you're not
breaking the laws of the united states
you should be allowed to be on twitter
and people can block you or mute you or
whatever it might be but the babylon bee
is suspended because of a joke and then
even though still very few people are
talking about this it's important to
note that tucker carlson the number one
rated host in the history of cable news
is suspended right now for the exact
same thing for basically saying rachel
levine is a man not a woman a biological
man not a woman that is a fact that is
an uncomfortable fact but that is a fact
so elon musk is defending the bee i
suspect that the babylon b will be back
on there soon which also leads us
perhaps to believe that a certain orange
man might be back on there